exactly we're here with the hero of the
day Maxim is here welcome Maxim um I was
wondering what did you eat what did you
do in order to succeed to play so well
today what happened I'm joking I mean of
course you're one of the best players
yeah u i mean for year I've been having
tough uh tournaments in Blitz for some
reason um few years ago I was playing
well every day of Blitz but today it
felt a bit vintage H yes yes so what did
you do in order to get ready for this
one nothing too special but generally
like every day before Blitz I would just
go and do some s some tactics and I did
feel a bit sharp so you know but
sometimes it's also like you don't F
shop and then uh it reverberates on your
play but yeah I felt sh and it
reverberated quite well so what kind of
tactics I mean two string move or
something it's tactics I mean it's B
tactics so you don't want to do
calculation like you want to to check
your abits exactly okay so it worked
really well today I don't know how many
points did you score at the end seven
seven points out of nine I mean great
result yeah they especially couple of
clean games I would say especially the
one with Wesley felt nice yeah so which
game which one of the brilliances we
will show uh to our public today which
one was the most most interesting for
you yeah I think this one so have the
game with Wesley yes okay yeah I played
this anti Marshal actually in the grand
Swiss with this idea with H4
mhm and I
think this is supposed to be slightly
inacurate but I don't know maybe maybe
C5 was too early anyway I
felt like this was complicated middle
game I wasn't sure about my play at all
but
uh let's say then it got interesting so
I go Knight F5 I go Queen C1 and this
was the moment I thought was nice ah yes
of course everybody was 95 what a move
huh yeah it's not forced actually Knight
F Knight F but maybe it's the same yeah
it's not possible not to make a move
like that yes like everything is hanging
so let's put one more piece I mean if it
loses I definitely don't play it but uh
turn out it's good move and then
yeah yeah then I feel like I played well
Queen F4 was also nice to keep playing
yeah and King G8 Rook E3 felt very
difficult so Bishop G7 is understandable
but then I was already very happy cuz I
get E5 all the time and yeah here any
time he goes Bishop D4 I have E5 and I'm
well actually no I thought this was
winning but I missed Queen C5 or no I
missed Knight F6 but this is okay so
what move after Knight D7 um there's no
move yeah okay so this was still okay
for him but wow it felt for you that you
were you were winning here at this
moment yes well I mean with my with such
pawns it looks like it yeah then it felt
very nice the center everything yeah AB
falling apart mhm what was the reaction
of Wesley when you played this move
night5 uh I think he had time to see it
because uh I took my hand and was
putting it under the Knight on F3 before
I played so no reaction like maybe if I
play it instantly maybe there would have
been some reaction how can you explain
that there were so many decisive games
today you know like only a few draws
like what was happening inside of the
hall it's not the same it's not the same
yes it rapid is too slow nowadays you
know so classical let's not talk about
it but rapid is too slow for so so we we
we come and play great games of Rapid uh
very solid but um in Blitz of course
mistakes happen and brillian is up as
well yes exactly so what's happening
tomorrow you have this distance
between between the second place that's
uh have you checked how many points you
have and other I I know how much it's
two points historically it's absolutely
no Guaranty mhm so I'll need to play
very well tomorrow and we'll see how
that goes yeah exactly okay thank you so
much Maxim and all the best of luck for
you tomorrow see you tomorrow yeah thank
you thank you thank you Anastasia thank
you Max